[Applaus] [Musik]
SAS und sowas darf sich immer noch christliches
Abendland nennen Paula jo so jetzt reicht wir
fordern unsere christlichen marenrechte
zurück okay dann heißt der Christbaum
nur noch Baum die Christdemokraten nur noch
Demokraten und Christian Lindner nur noch jan
ist mir egal aber mit den Christdemokraten
will ich persönlich sprechen ne wir mal den
Chef hoch ja Sie wissen schon wie viel
Uhr es gerade da unten ist es ist an der
Zeit bitte kommt sofort
[Musik]
halleluja und wo bin ich jetzt hier bitte Paula
der er kennt seinen eigenen Schöpfer nicht mehr
soll das heißen ich bin tot aber ich stand doch
erst am Anfang meiner politischen Karriere ja ja
die ist tot Friedrich aber mit dir habe ich noch
ein Wörtchen zu reden gott braucht meinen Rat das
überrascht mich nicht wegen eurer Vorschläge zur
Migrationspolitik habe ich mich entschlossen dass
ihr das C im Namen nicht mehr tragen dürft dann
heiße ich ab sofort friedri nein nein im Parteien
es es heißt du sollst dein nächsten Leben wie dich
selbst und nicht du sollst dein nächsten Leben wie
dich selbst es sei denn du hast das Gefühl dass
die kommonen überlastet sind ja das liegt daran
dass sie das Konzept der nächsten Liebe nicht zu
Ende gedacht haben nicht war den nach dem nächsten
kommt ja der nächste und dann der nächste und das
ist ja dann der übernächste und für den gilt das
ja gar nicht mehr vor allem dann nicht wenn er
unsere Kommunen überlastet warum schaut ihr immer
nur auf die Kommunen wo es nicht läuft schaut doch
mal die Kommunen an wo es läuft hier Rüsselsheim
oder hebbertshausen diese oberbayerische Gemeinde
die fünfm so viel geflüchtete aufnimmt wie geplant
sie bringt sie sogar in Arbeit hier ja beim Bauhof
beim Maler beim Bäcker sie 90 Menschen arbeiten
hier aus 14 Nationen uns wird gar nicht mehr geben
wenn wenn wir nicht so viel Leute aus anderen
Ländern beschäftigen würden wenn jemand ausfällt
oder was ist keiner dabei der sagt ich komme jetzt
nicht weil ich morgen frei hab sondern die ruft an
und dann ist der steht um eins auf der mattealcht
Job den viele hierzulande wegen der nächtlichen
Arbeitszeiten gar nicht mehr machen wollen siehst
du verstehst du und die Uni Hildesheim hat eine
Umfrage gemacht 60% der Kommunen haben dort gesagt
wir schaffen das die Realität an der ich mich
als Politiker orientiere ist die Stimmung in
der Bevölkerung sie wollen doch nicht ernsthaft
behaupten wir hätten kein Problem das tue ich
ja gar nicht aber ich sage es ist lösbar ja und
zwar mit Abschiebungen warum denn nicht mit Geld
für kitaapätze für Sozialwohnung und Schulen die
Leute wen m doch nicht wegen Geld für kitaapätze
Sozialwohnungen oder Schulen und die Leute sollen
mich wählen schließlich muss ich Kanzler werden
Friedrich ich kenne sämtliche Paralleluniversen
und in keinem einzigen davon bist du
Kanzler es sei denn du gehst jetzt darunter und du
forderst mehr Geld für kapätze sozial und Schulen
ich fordere weniger Flüchtlinge das ist einfacher
verstehen sie es sind einfach zu viele okay ihr
habt es nicht anders gewollt okay tafelnummer nein
nicht die die andere die die andere wo wir den
Leuten immer Dinge Erk ja so hier da hier das seid
ihr 85 Millionen Einwohner 5 Millionen Menschen
sind zu euch gekommen wegen fluchtvertreibung oder
weil sie Schutz bei euch suchen was aber ich habe
immer gehört 3 Millionen das ist ja noch besser
für mich also ich meine schlechter für alle da
sind doch sicherlich haufenweise Leute dabei die
gar kein Recht haben hier zu bleiben verstehen sie
und deswegen die Zahlen müssen runter zunächst mal
sind das keine Zahlen sondern das sind Menschen ja
und sie stellen die Menschen hier als Punkte da
ist das besser ja okay technisch aber aber also
jeder einzelne Punkt steht für 10 000 Menschen
ich kann ja schlecht 5 Millionen Menschen hier
ins Studio holen sie geben also zu wir haben zu
wenig Platz und wenn die erstmal alle weg sind
dann wird alles wieder gut oh probieren wir doch
mal Friedrich komm schie ab welche Gruppe soll
den ein was was willst du na ja gut dann fangen
wir doch gleich mit der großen weißen Gruppe da
an was sind denn das das sind vertriebene nach
dem Zweiten Weltkrieg raus raus damit weg damit
ja W sich nur mancher wundern dass sie plötzlich
seine deutsche Oma abgeschoben haben was haltt na
die Omas dürfen bleiben das sind ja deutsche die
nach Deutschland geflüchtet sind besser geht's
ja gar nicht eben und die sind ja im Schnitt 82
die nehme ich euch e bald ab ja wie gut also dann
nehme ich dann nehmen wir den blauen Kreis da was
ist das weg damit sorry habe ich vergessen geht
gar nicht halbe Million Bürgerkriegsflüchtlinge
vor allem aus dem exjugoslawien das die haben
leider schon bleibericht ja gut dann nehmen
wir eben den nächsten Block nehmen wir den
gelben Kreis was sind Paul gib mal nach unten
weit der CDU Vorsitzender schickt 100ta000 von
Ukrainerinnen zurück in den Krieg ja aber im
Westen der Ukraine ist doch eigentlich Paula
das tut er nicht ja gut dann nehmen wir eben den
orangenen Kreis da okay Paula gib mal nach unten
weit der CDU Vorsitzender schickt eine Million
syer zurück in Assads Diktatur was ja ist denn da
überall Diktatur Paula das tut er nicht ja gut
dann nehmen wir eben jetzt denn den schwarzen
Kreis wer ist das sie meinen Irak und Iran Paula
lassen Sie es gut sein gut was ist mit den lilanen
da wer ist denn das sind 400.000 Afghanen ja
gut der Krieg ist ja da vorbei ich meine was
kann denn da jetzt Taliban gut irgendwas ist
ja immer die Taliban foltert die ortskräfte die
ihren Soldaten geholfen haben gegen die Taliban
zu kämpfen ihr habt versprochen letztes Jahr 1000
ortskräfte pro Monat nach Deutschland zu holen
ja und dazu stehen wir Deutschland hat es bisher
geschafft in 12 Monaten 13 Leute zu holen gut wir
brauchen jetzt im Moment auch eher Fachkräfte und
keine ortskräfte die bleiben ja gut aber wen
darf ich denn dann überhaupt abschieben was
ist denn da mit den pinken z.B die kommen aus
Ländern in die man niemand zurückschicken kann
also so wie sie das hier darstellen könnte man
meinen die Leute hätten alle einen guten Grund
zu fliegen ach was deswegen gewährt ihr ja auch
aktuell 70% der Menschen Asyl ach und dann können
wir also keinen einzigen was sind den was sind
denn die roten Punkte was ist mit denen da das
sind jetzt 280 000 ausreisepflichtige yes ich
wusste es alle weg hervorrag Paula 230 000 davon
haben allerdings eine sogenannte Duldung was wie
nein das dulde ich nicht das sind doch bestimmt
alles illegale die ät verschleier haben vor allem
deshalb eine Duldung weil sie h eine Ausbildung
machen Arbeiten krank sind oder schwanger denkt
denn von denen eigentlich keiner daran dass ich
Kanzler werden muss und was ist mit diesen fünf
roten Punkten da das sind was ich Studierende
aus dem Ausland ja weg mit denen Touristen aus
Kanada die abschieben mit aller herte die hab
Visum vergessen zu zu verlängern die die einzigen
die laut Bundesregierung tatsächlich abschieben
sind diese 21000 dort ja na da sollte mal
einer sagen ich habe keinen Punkt ich habe
sogar zwei und jetzt kommt ja noch das neue
abschiebegesetz dazu gratuliere das sind noch
mal 600 Abschiebungen mehr und wenn ihr diese
21600 Leute abschiebt dann sieht's für eure
85 Millionen Leute so aus na ja aber mit dem
neuen abschiebegesetetzt dürfen wir die Leute
wenigstens nachts aus ihren Betten reißen und
das entlastet die Kommunen wie wir müssen nun
mal Härte zeigen sonst ist n J die ganze Welt zu
Gast in Deutschland ist nicht nächstes Jahr bei
euch die fußballuropameisterschaft ja furchtbar
da sehen dann alle wieder wie schön es hier ist
wieso spielen die Deutschen nicht [Musik]
mit wenn wir wenn wir wenn wir schon nicht
abschieben können dann müssen wir wenigstens
verhindern dass immer mehr Leute kommen indem
wir alles abschaffen was die Leute zu uns
locken würde z.B unser üppiges Bürgergeld
aber das ist doch gar nicht für Asylbewerber
jetzt sagen Sie es selbst nein ich meine sehen
Sie die diese Leute bekommen die bekommen kein
Bürgergeld bekommen 410 € aus dem sogenannten
Asylbewerber leistungsgesetz verstehen sie oder
182 € wenn sie in Sammelunterkünften Hausen rufen
Sie es noch lauter vom Balkon auf dass sich noch
mehr Menschen auf den Weg machen ja die einzigen
pullfaktoren die die Migrationsforschung wirklich
gelten lässt sind Familie Freunde eine starke
Wirtschaft oder eine demokratische Rechtsordnung
genau da müss wir ran ich sage nur Dänemark die
haben die Sozialleistungen stark gedrosselt ja und
deswegen jetzt ein Armut und kriminalitätsproem in
sogenannten parallelgesellschaftsvierteln ja aber
die Kriminellen aus diesen Vierteln bekommen ein
doppelt so hohes Strafmaß wie die anderen was hat
denn das noch mit Rechtsstaat zu tun ich sage ja
da müssen wir ran und ich sage auch Ruanda was was
was was was sagen sie Ruanda haben Sie noch nie
vom Ruanda Modell gehört damit die Menschen sich
nicht auf den gefährlichen Weg über das Mittelmeer
machen bringt man alle geflüchteten per Flugzeug
nach Ruanda um dann dort über ihren Asylantrag
entscheiden zu können Moment eine der reichsten
Demokratien der Welt möchte keine geflüchteten
mehr aufnehmen sie möchte viel mehr dass die
geflüchteten am am Rande der EU aufgenommen
dann per Flugzeug tausende von Kilometer um
den Globus geflogen werden nach Ruanda einem
der kleinsten und ärmsten Länder der Welt und
doort einer Autokratie sollen dann 100000 von
rechtssicheren Asylverfahren durchgeführt
werden die Afrikaner nehmen ja auch unseren
Elektroschrott [Applaus] Paula ich
muss direkt zur Welt sprechen okay
darf der brende Dornbusch sein oder
soll ich dein sohnann anrufen nein
nein Fernsehen direkt und was ist dann bitte
mit mir jetzt er hat keine Bleibeperspektive
hören Sie das Randa Mod hören Sie das Ruanda
Modell ist ja von meinem Kollegen Hendrik
wüst das sagt ja schon alles und wenn sie
mich jetzt nach unten bringen vielleicht
könnten Sie mich gleich beim Kanzleramt
abliefern dann geht das für mich gleich
schneller ja kein Problem da müssen
sie da vorne links aber passen Sie auf
vors [Musik]
her wir haben was vergessen was denn na das Abo
und die Glocke was dann dann war das hier alles
ganz umsonst ich fürchte ja vielleicht wissen
unsere Zuschauer ja auch selbst wo sie abonnieren
können dass jetzt noch zwei weitere Videos gucken
können stimmt unsere Zuschauer sind ja sehr
klug